in 2019 the North Carolina coastline is
in the grip of a disturbing string of
shark attacks two different species
bowls and black tips have attacked four
swimmers in little more than six weeks
the cause is a mystery the final piece
of the puzzle might be found not in the
waters of North Carolina but in the
skies above just months before the spike
the Tar Heel State was struck by one of
the most destructive storms on record
hurricane Florence on September 13th
2018 100 mile-per-hour winds toppled
trees and caused widespread power
outages upwards of 30 inches of rain
Unleashed catastrophic flooding so how
might this devastating storm connect to
the upwelling of shark attacks in 2019
according to coastal habitat expert
Taylor Moretti it could come down to one
of the state's most unique geographical
features a 3500 square mile network of
estuaries
that's wedged between the barrier
islands and the mainland eared dozens of
freshwater rivers and streams flow into
the salty sea it's a complex ecosystem
full of life and it's built upon a tiny
unassuming plant seagrass seagrass is
actually not grass at all
it's a lily that is capable of living in
salt environments it has a root system
it flowers seagrass provides vital
shelter for all manner of creatures this
right here is a tiny little blue crab
very very teeny the animals that make
sea grasses are home to start from small
microscopic creatures like anthropods
and I go up to larger creatures like
crabs and smaller fish these small
marine animals attract larger species
like sea turtles and manatees which in
turn draws in sharks atlantic sharp nose
bowls black tips and even the occasional
large tiger come from the oceans into
these estuaries to look for prey it's
this food chain that provides North
Carolina with its rich array of marine
life but during the storm this chain
gets broken
intense tropical storms can have an
impact on the shark fauna of these
estuaries and it can be long-lasting
when tropical storms pass through they
often leave a lot of fresh water in
their way when a storm hits it dumps
fresh water across the region both along
the coast and inland the water that
originates on land travels to the
estuaries via rivers and streams but
along the way it picks up some unwanted
hitchhikers sediment and pollution the
contaminants are a toxic stew that's
deadly for sea grass studies have shown
that flood sediment can bury entire
meadows other areas are decimated when
suspended debris blocks out crucial
sunlight it can take up to five years
for the plants to grow back and when the
seagrass vanishes so does the Sharks
prey
and that reverberates up the entire food
chain so shorts they typically will
leave the system this chain reaction can
have dire consequences for beach goers
if the Sharks are not in the estuary we
know they're not on land so they're out
near shore
[Music]
you